[Music]
[Applause]
is Roger Bennett he is a co-founder of
men in Blazers media Network he's a big
deal Eva Longoria is the men in Blazers
guest on Twitch kicking off at 4 45 PM
Eastern on Sunday
well look at that Eva Longoria
hi Raj oh Danny P it's a joy to be with
you do I can let's tell you Paul
Finebaum you had a photo of me and him
side by side to promote this show and I
thought oh that looks handsome it looks
just like me but you could be my son or
me if I had a lot of work done he's
perfect
help me understand what these sports
stars buying into British soccer clubs
what I heard you you've been offered one
I'm fascinated I uh well kind of offered
two of them
yeah why just have one go bankrupt on
you when you destroy two from afar as
well mine was in France and one was in
Italy
um God Dan you don't want to get mucked
up in that Italian crap let me tell you
that is that is that is you'll end up in
the pine Baron season three it's
Sopranos before you know it you'll be
wondering how did I get here what are
these guys what are you guys getting in
the end these these celebrities getting
out of this and then what do the clubs
get out of Tom Brady buying in or JJ
Watt buying it wow JJ Watt buying into
Burnley it's an incredible thing he's
been on our show a ton JJ I've watched
his passion for this football this
gentleman who grew up in Wisconsin
hockey player football player you know
American Sports lover falling in love
with the game of of English football now
partnering with Burnley football club
first of all it's incredible to witness
that you know when you look at the long
ball game of when I came to America in
the early 90s and and and and and and uh
the congressman Kemp who was the
quarterback was it for the Rams uh
walking around Congress that when
America was awarded the World Cup saying
it's important for American children to
know that football is where you rush
with it and and and and and and pass the
ball with your hands not where you kick
it one is American capitalism the other
is European socialism how far we've come
and it is bloody joyous that we are open
to the world's game and and JJ is a
symbol of that but what do the teams get
with
um with JJ Watt with Incredible Tom
Brady if Tom Brady's team ever plays JJ
Watts that will just be Boom the team I
support Everton football club are so
crap and so miserable so dark they'll
probably end up getting Johnny Manziel
buying into them or something but um but
what do they get they can't piece they
get a platform they get a chance right
now America is still and this is you
know men in Blazers uh rise has been a
testament to the fact that this
footballer first nation which was to the
game of football like space to Captain
Kurt the final frontier we are falling
in love with this sport the biggest
teams in the world Barcelona you know
Manchester United even wrexham which we
can talk about which I'm fascinated by
what Rob uh mcelhenney who's actually on
our show today
um we're just launching out on YouTube
and and Ryan
um putting you know taking wrecks and
using their speaker they've made it a
tiny massive club and what they get with
Tom Brady or Leeds United who
essentially have the richest GoFundMe of
owners now the 49ers are in Jordan
spieths in Phelps is in my mate Larry
Nance is in TJ McConnell
um they take a GoFundMe a very wealthy
athletes have brought Leeds United they
get a mouthpiece to speak to that
American audience which is gold dust for
these teams right now
um the Orlando City coach called the
game against Messi and inner Miami a
circus because of the officiating
is it are they going to give messy
special treatment
oh man I love the Orlando coach is the
only one who's actually beating the drum
about that no one gives a crap what do
we want we want messy morsels we want
golden nuggets can we just say this man
has arrived this tiny man he's a giant
talk about Billboards that are speaking
to the entire world now welded onto the
American game and we've got a World Cup
coming Danny p uh 2026 we've got the
biggest teams in the world uh salivating
about playing here in the United States
and we have Lionel Messi this little
demigod walking amongst us scoring for
fun yes it's a bit like if LeBron
decided you know what a fantasy fancy
gonna play basketball in London for a
little bit oh I just scored I just
scored 120 points this game 57 boards
are through in a very healthy 37 assist
that didn't really break a sweat but
what he's doing is several times a game
scoring goals that make the football
world's nipples go hard and say in
America America America and that's
forget the Orlando City thing you and
the Orlando City coach are the only two
people that have mentioned the
officiated okay wait is is messy though
maybe making a mockery of the MLS
because here's a guy who's what 36
coming over here and he's you know
showcasing his talents does it make the
league look inferior oh that's a very
good question I mean right now Messi is
going to a supermarket and getting I
think it was Publix he went to he
brought some
um he put some Lucky Charms in his
shopping bag Lucky Charms The Breakfast
of Champions
um and that got public something like
3.7 million dollars of global free
Global uh advertising everything this
man does when he goes to the pasta
restaurant that has a 3.5 rating on Yelp
uh but he goes there it becomes almost
like a Transcendent holy site there's
thousands then flock to
um so I don't yeah I I I ultimately
there will be a point
um where it will become it is in danger
of becoming like my stupid LeBron in
London analogy we're not there yet but
it is incredible he's playing with a he
gets a CIS magical assists from this
player called Robert Taylor
um who's a despite his name sounding
like he's just been plucked from the
streets of hello cockles of muscle South
London he's actually from Finland this
man if you look at his biography he has
played in like the let's just say the
anus of world football he's played for
Finnish teams I didn't even know existed
has washed up in Orlando uh in in in
Miami and is now ditching incredible
assists what happened to you you're
given nipples and anus here in a span of
about three minutes here it's it's a
women's world cup dance I've been up
since 2 A.M every day for the past two
and a half weeks
um well the Premier League teams have
been flowing across our nation training
your Chelsea's your Manchester United
your exams these are days of Bountiful
uh Wonder for those who love football in
this nation and just trying to keep up
to it
um I think it's turned me into into a
slightly dark figure but I am excited
for your show I'm excited for Todd is he
a Daryl Hall or is he a John Oates
that's what I can't get my head around
in this moment Tyler you would John
Daryl well you got to have them together
they're a pair if I had to pick one
because she's the lead singer I'd have
to go with Hall so well
yeah okay yeah I mean are you Stockton
or Malone is really what we're asking
here no so I think I'm a I think I
shouldn't go there at all sorry I'm
taking that one back I'm a John Oates I
think in life it's the John Oates quiet
knowing your mustache is going to steal
every photograph I like that okay I like
that approach uh I am excited for you
guys tonight
How concerned should we be about our
girls maybe bowing out
oh women yes oh
um
for context the United States uh trying
to get a three-peat in the World Cup
um they've gone back to back they've
never done less than the semi-final in
this tournament here we have Title Nine
here it's a unique Advantage a built-in
Advantage
um and this world cup it's been it's
been dark it's been humbling they've
been unsyncopated
um it's been a little bit like if you
tuned in for the Last Dance only to see
Jordan and Pippin crash out in the in
the first round be swept in the first
round of the playoffs that's the the
possibility they're in the red they made
the round of 16 they made The Knockouts
they've yet to find their form they are
the most Peerless team I've ever seen
athletically mentally this generation to
generation tenacity this generation to
generation winning mentality
um and we police Sweden 4 45 a.m which
I'm gonna watch with Eva Longoria
um which could be for evil the football
could be a challenge being with me could
be definitely even worse
um but it is a real possibility but to
flip it on its head wait how did you get
Eva Longoria though she loves football
she's the owner of Angel City uh in Alex
Jones a Liga MX team going back to your
original thing okay for longer is and
it's huge nakaka
um who I actually adore in league of MX
is proper football
um yeah when England played America in
the men's World Cup I watched it with
Matthew Mcconaughey live on Twitch
people love watching along and watching
people watching football I we're playing
Sweden um who are very powerful very
good very blonde
um I mean I prefer it it's like play
it's a pro it almost feels like we're
gonna play like the whole of ABBA
um on a football field and the US so far
has been like the New York Mets version
of the US women and I do believe please
God before Sunday night we will summon
that tenacity of all that that mental
ability that football women's football
has exploded that and in the past we
used to Steamroller over all comers but
now people are bloody good Morocco Haiti
Jamaica well this goes back this is the
Dream Team so basketball what the dream
team did to the world that's what uh
Women's World Cup team has done you can
use that if you want is it done you're
giving me gold it is exactly that the
red it's ultimately a great thing for
the game of basketball the you know oh
yeah the global side of the game it
means that the days of America just it
automatically opening up a can of whoop
ass and whatever happens in this world
cup you know our footballers that we
develop here are very athletic and
mentally just unparalleled but the
European game the African game now
um you know even Morocco have been the
darling of this world cup have you had
Messi on your show men in Blazers had
Messi on the show
um Lionel Messi he doesn't say a lot Dan
as we have an American analogy to that
athlete the athlete who just says
everything with his play but really
outside of commercials I mean you see
Lionel Messi eating a lot of these
um on commercials you see Lionel Messi
drinking a lot of Pepsi but verbally
um he doesn't say a lot and it's almost
added to his his deep deep Mystique
um so the answer is no it's a
long-winded way of saying no you haven't
had messy on men in Blazers and he won't
come on the DP show now you know you're
supporting the Orlando city manager
that's the reason why I'm not getting
messy is because I I'm I'm backing the
uh Orlando head coach Messi was like oh
my God I just love The Dan Patrick Show
you know like Daryl Hannah learned
English in Splash by watching uh daytime
quiz games Lionel Messi's no doubt been
sharpening his English by watching The
Dan Patrick Show he's like Taylor man to
his wife be like Paul Finebaum he is
demi-god
why is he not playing your kisses on my
lips he's saying to his wife
um like arguing about which Daryl Hall
Classics what bangers Fritz is going to
play tonight and now he's just heard and
then he's like oh my God damn Patrick in
the Orlando City coach dad man he's
called his agent said the interview with
DP you strike me as a guy who was a big
Wham fan
I mean if you don't appreciate the work
of Wham are you really alive where are
we going with this God somebody Wham
early stuff was was just immense
Careless Whisper it's uh before that
before that when these guys broke out
just the two of them just Lund North
London Lads on television no that wasn't
good no that rap that rap song was uh it
was amazing they had they we didn't know
what a suntan was we're Sun had not yet
been invented in England when we saw
them and they were just like golden they
didn't wear a shirt which is a dangerous
game just leather jackets no shirts yeah
on television I was like oh my God it's
like I haven't felt that like oh my God
that's sexy since I saw that photo of
Paul Finebaum this morning
uh be on your best behavior with Eva
Longoria
um I I will I will I do know that
Messi's people are now got a vacant
interview slot after they ditched you so
I might I'm definitely on vessel I love
the ladies I love the Pepsi I've got my
messy look right behind me actually I've
got messy bottles of Bud because I know
he does the bird as well as the Lucky
Charms so it will happen but Danny P we
are living in Incredible Days for
football of course we are even since
I've been coming on yeah and soccer I
mean so both of them yeah by the way can
we just say I've gone there's a Chicago
Bears fan from just Bleak wandering in
the desert for like 40 years to just a
surging sense of I almost feel sorry for
other teams we're going to be that
dynastic now are you lonely
I mean you strike me as you're lonely
you run to me why'd you say that
I don't know it just it kind of if
you're you're surrounded by toys in a
small room and the Chicago Bears
Dan Dan I've got to tell you I am uh I
am genuine I I feel
I will tell you this you can never be
lonely when you're a sports fan because
just the darkness of being a White Sox
fan
a Chicago Bears fan an Everton fan
um now the US women slightly challenged
um you learned that when something
mildly good happens you just celebrate
that sense of of meaning and that deep
sense of connection to other uh fans and
not waste a single second so I'm
probably one of the most joyous and
upbeat uh human beings you will have on
the show uh this year until you bought
Lionel Messi slash Eva Longoria slash
John Oates uh I will wear that mantle
um but ultimately it is I watch sports
Dan telling you more than you want to
know yeah
Roger I have to go I know you're lonely
and I didn't know we were talking to
anybody else I thought it's just you and
made anything we we well we might not be
talking to anybody else we started off
talking to people but uh have fun this
weekend men in Blazers
okay that's uh Roger Bennett co-host of
men in Blazers Eva Longoria is going to
join the show coming up they had a half
million people watch the last match with
them pretty good stuff